ich würde einmal die lage ganz klar
sowohl du sie alle am tisch uli einmal
ganz kurz einige rate einblenden die uns
vielleicht paul ronzheimer einmal kurz
erklären kann damit wir alle einmal auch
abgeholt werden die wahrscheinlich denn
auch noch einen sieg der ukraine ist
paul vielleicht kannst du einmal den
stand erneut ist die frage so zu sagen
was man was ich so ein niederlage
definiert genau richtig also das erste
ziel eben großstädte zu europa kiew
sieht man dort nicht das ist weiter
links aber auch die prosa politischer
oder hak i sind gescheitert was momentan
passiert das sieht man dort auf der
karte bei slogans und kramer tors das
ist auch die region aus der ich
zurückgekehrt bin dort gibt es massive
geländegewinne von städten zwischen
10.000 und 30.000 riemanns zum beispiel
dass eine stadt die sieht man dort nicht
aber das nächste ziel wird florians
seien im übrigen eine stadt die bekannt
geworden ist dadurch dass 2014 die von
russland unterstützten separatisten
diese stadt als erstes angenommen haben
und das ziel der russischen soldaten ist
dort ein kleinen kessel zu schließen und
sagen zu können man hat lugansk und don
was erobert und das wäre dann
tatsächlich etwas was man der russischen
bevölkerung als vermeintlichen sieg
verkaufen kann denn die propaganda läuft
dort seit jahren in einer richtung dass
man sagt angeblich würden die ukraine
den don was angreifen und dort ja
kriegsverbrechen durch finden was eine
absolute lüge ist von daher würde das
aber sozusagen verfangen in der
russischen bevölkerung
ich muss sagen anders wir hatten das ja
heute auch im verteidigungsausschuss in
der sondersitzung und auch im
auswärtigen ausschuss gab es ja auch
eine bieten die unterrichtung anders als
medial dargestellt wurde kann man ja
eigentlich schon alleine von der karte
aussehen dass das russische militär
langsam aber stetig fortschritte macht
so das wurde erst mal anders dargestellt
was wir alles erzählt bekommen haben
hier so schlecht aufgestellt und so
weiter also
der außenminister lavrov hat gesagt das
ist absolute priorität ist denn bombers
einzunehmen den gesamten donnerstag
noch die folgende frage stellen sie
sagen zu recht natürlich ist man
solidarisch und leidet ja auch mit mit
der bevölkerung in der ukraine aufgrund
dieses angriff kriegen ist aber die
frage ist doch trotzdem was es
verantwortungsbewusstes handeln hier ist
es das dass man mehr öl ins feuer gießt
durch mehr schwere waffen in diesen
krieg zu schicken oder ob man jetzt
alles unternimmt um eine eine eskalation
um eine eskalation eigene eigene direkte
direkte gefahr entschuldigen sie herr
kubicki aber dass selbst der
us-präsident beiden hat in seinem
eigenen meinungsbeitrag im
kindergartenbereich nachts ohne darauf
hingewiesen warum sie keine
kampfflugzeuge und keine panzer liefern
und auch die diskussion um die mehrfach
raketen hat er selber angesprochen
das könnte zu einer eskalation führen
könnte zur vergeltungsmaßnahmen der
russen führen die haben ja auch heute
darauf reagiert und haben gesagt dass
sie eventuell eben das als öl ins feuer
gießen sehen und es gibt natürlich diese
eskalationspotenzial gibt es weil die
eskalation dominanz in der ukraine in
diesem krieg bei russland liegt dem
eingang halten den gastbeiträgen um
beiden saison anschauen im wortlaut bei
so genau also erst einmal ganz genau so
ganz genau zu zeigen also beim hat
einmal nämlich eine new york times
gesagt amerikas ziel ist klar wir wollen
in demokratisch unabhängige souveräne
und wohlhabende ukraine mit den mitteln
um weitere aggression abzuwehren und sie
gegen sie zu verteidigen und hier haben
wir jetzt diesen satz den sie
wahrscheinlich meinten dass kein krieg
zwischen der nato und russland gewollt
ist und dass sie auch unter der zweite
satz ist dass sie auch so sehr sehr
putin nicht zustimmen und seine handlung
als empörung empfinden die vereinigten
staaten nicht versuchen werden seinen
sturz herbeizuführen aber in dem
gastbeitrag wird noch nicht dass man
nichts machen soll das hab ich ja auch
nicht ich habe sogar eine kampfflugzeuge
und keine panzer von den usa bisher
geliefert worden sind genau im ganztag
eskalationsgefahr sehen das sieht die us
administration und das sieht auch die
bundesregierung offensichtlich auch wenn
sie das selber beschlossen hat und das
möchte für den fall das herr jörges hier
recht hat dass sie das bewusst nicht
machen und vielleicht noch andere
staaten und ich finde dass wenn
überhaupt denn wenn die ich das
eigentlich richtig dass man das nicht
machen weil es bei uns ja viel mehr in
krieg mit hineinzieht aber wie man sie
lässt relation schaffen machen es macht
ja wirklich fassungslos weil die einst
nicht eskalieren sind die russen die
russen marschieren weiter und dann sagen
sie wir wollen demokratie keine
möglichkeit geben sich zu verteidigen da
können sie sagen da könnte ich gleich
aufgeben kubicki sehen sie nicht dass es
eine eskalationsgefahr birgt wenn wir
noch mehr schwere waffen durch die
ausbildung an diesen schweren waffen der
ukrainischen soldaten zum beispiel auch
kriegs beteiligte werden wie der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestages
sehen die diese gefallen ich sehe die
eskalationsgefahr wahr das hab ich da
auch die lobby aber auch die gefahr dass
wir russen werden wenn ihnen nichts
entgegengesetzt nicht zu stoppen sein
werden die werfen vakuum bomben diversen
phosphorbombe finale der lack werden
wollen sie bis wohin wollen sie waffen
liefern so irgendeine atommacht herr
kubicki das geht doch nicht thomas geht
darum dass die ukraine die lage versetzt
wird konventionell die russischen vor
die vordringen die russen und gruppen
auch ansonsten starten die denken
tatsächlich das konventionell mir durch
immer mehr aufrüstung der ukraine wir
gegen so eine macht dort tatsächlich
einen sieg das hat man aber nicht
gesehen oder das hat man auch hier auf
gesehen das hat man gesehen dass man in
weiteren was ist wenn das riecht man wir
haben ja sagen nach hause schicken und
sagen die russen dürfen mit jan born
berlin besetzt alles andere
nein ich sage ihnen dass wir in einen
krieg hineinschlittern wenn wir uns
immer mehr mit schweren waffen und der
ausbildung an den soldaten an diesen
schwer bleiben wir mal bei der frank
vielleicht sogar noch mehr an hilfen
machen ich sage die eskalation dominanz
sie haben mich missverstanden ich sag ja
trage dass die inne bei russland liegt
aber weil diese dominanz eben bei
russland liegt müssen wir aufpassen was
sie
doch mal wir sind nicht im krieg
herrnsheimer sie scheinen ja mental im
krieg zu sein ja aber wir sind nicht im
krieg gegen russland das möchte aber
das ist zu unterschiedlich haben gericht
habe mit dem wir gemeinsam
sicher nicht
ich habe da besser waren sie von
siegfried
es geht doch darum mit wir meine ich die
westliche gemeinschaft die nato wenn wir
einfach akzeptieren dass russland die
ukraine die die ukraine über allen hat
angegriffen hat die tausende menschen
ermordet hatte die kriegsverbrechen wie
ein buddha angerichtet hat wenn wir
einfach sagen okay lassen wir das
geschehen denn ohne die usa insbesondere
ohne die usa hätte hier nicht bestehen
können das ist doch ganz klar das heißt
wir müssen die ukraine in die lage
versetzen sich gegen einen
kriegsverbrechen und gegen einen
kriegsverbrecher zu wehren und wenn wir
das nicht tun so wie sie das nämlich
fordert sie sagen ja wir sollen keine
waffen wir sollen keine heilige kuh
bleiben kriegen konnte ich nicht
verlangen nicht weil wir nein wenn wir
das erreichen werden wir das tun was wir
sagen dann werden noch ganz viele
butscher passieren dann sind ins haus
willkommen entscheider mordet das ist
dass sie werden weder ania magen
erfordern dass die am ende vorher
passiert am ende fordern bedeutet das
nach hausen dem haarschnitt werden von
ihren russischen nachbarn sie nicht von
ihren russischen fahrrad tausende
menschen am ort ich weiß auf dem niveau
das ist hier niveau aber vielleicht habe
ich auch darauf hinweisen der hundertste
erklärung als die ukraine ihre hat er
darum alle vier mächte des
weltsicherheitsrats russland frankreich
großbritannien und auch china die
territoriale integrität der ukraine
vertraglich versprochen da diese
territorien dieser vertrag ist gebrochen
worden ja in russland jetzt ist die
spannende frage
worauf will man sich nochmal einlassen
wenn dieses versprechen an die ukraine
wir helfen euch für den fall dass sie
angegriffen werden wenn das nicht
eingehalten wird was würden wir denn
machen wenn jetzt russische truppen weil
wir auch eine russisch sprechende
bevölkerung den baltischen staaten haben
estland litauen und da ist mich die
angst wirklich vorhanden ich war da die
angst wirklich vorhanden dort
einmarschieren würden werden auch sagen
bevor wir ein atomkrieg riskieren sollen
sie lieber bis an die ostsee weiter
marschieren und anschließend machen wir
den frieden 200 für eine ost berlin noch
kurz da wäre auch nicht so schlimm vor
nach denen oder wenn die russen dann wir
ich
glaube ich glaube weil ich absolut über
bedrohungen eskalation zu hin ich habe
es von anfang an ein fehler gehalten
auch was die furcht angeht vor der
anderen seite von russland dass die nato
sich vor russland fürchtet aber russland
nicht vor der nato das für die schon
sehr merkwürdig
ich halte es für einen schweren
strategischen fehler der nato von anfang
an erklärt zu haben wir wollen in die
auseinandersetzungen in der ukraine
nicht verstrickt werden
man offen halten damit die nato ist ein
verteidigung ist für die eigenen
mitglieder für nichts anderes
entschuldigung ist keine aggression da
wirklich und moment nicht verteidigt mit
den waffen die von der nato kommen da
wird die nato nicht verteidigt den den
punkt haben aber überschritten es ist in
einer art wie es angegriffen wir sind
dabei einen aggressor aufzuhalten der
auch zur bedrohung für die nato werden
kann aber mich interessiert in dem
zusammenhang die nato kann ich von mir
aus muss das gar nicht so laufen dann
gibt es eben eine koalition der willigen
die die ukraine unterstützen wenn die
ungarn sagen wir es so ich habe dabei
auch alleine wenn handwaffen wir müssen
auf jeden fall muss die ukraine instand
gesetzt werden durch die waffen ist
bekommt und wie kommt sie nicht aus
deutschland denn die kommen alle zu spät
vom vermutlich instand gesetzt werden ab
einem bestimmten punkt die russischen
truppen aufzuhalten definitiv es ist
doch erkennbar henry kissinger hat sogar
ausgesprochen weil es von den westlichen
politikern keiner sagt man muss sich
darauf einrichten dass russland einen
teil der ost ukraine und der krim und
weiter behält und nicht mehr hergibt das
halt umgekehrt weil er bei der man bei
der meister da mancher falsch halten
umgekehrt steigen das hat ja eine zweite
seite dann jede seite hat einen plan b
der ukraine wird es auch nicht gelingen
die russischen truppen daraus zu werfen
denn da hat frau dagdelen rechts ist
eine atommacht das lassen sie nicht
bieten irgendwas hinter die linie des 24
februar auch wieder ausgesetzt hat einer
gesagt auch meine hat die werden auch
irgendwie ein paar heiratete seit tagen
und wochen sagt er das ziel dass er so
etwas sagt jeden talenten etwas zurück
das ziel ist momentan festgelegt die
russischen truppen hinter die linie des
24 februar also sozusagen vor dem großen
krieg der russen gegen die ukraine zur
un das hat er als übergegangen ist auch
ein teil der ukraine verloren mir geht
es um die andere seite plan b der
ukraine ist ja nicht kann nicht mehr
sein die russischen truppen komplett aus
der ukraine rauszuwerfen und natürlich
musste dass sie heute nicht mehr
gelingen also die die krim frei zu
machen und die ost ukraine komplett frei
zum ist eine illusion
das heißt die ukraine muss sich darauf
konzentrieren ab wann beginnt die
ukraine ab welchen grenzen die wir in
die eu führen wollen und die sich
westlich orientiert und das muss auch
unser nachdenken sein und da muss die
ukraine instand gesetzt werden araber
und esoterik zu verteilen ist das ganze
immer noch realistisch zu betrachten und
zu sagen
herr moment aber wenn man sich sozusagen
im blut ihn anschaut und sagt dass er
handeln nach irgendeiner logik dann muss
man ja davon ausgehen dass diese
irgendwo fest gesetzt ist und all das
was war die putin getan hat hatte er
angekündigt in einem magazinbeitrag in
verschiedenen interviews haltern zu
kriegsbeginn und dieses ziel von
wladimir putin lautet eben nicht zu
sagen wie ich nehme teile des donners
und höre dann auf sondern das ziel ist
dass die ukraine und nicht mehr besteht
aber mal ganz kurz aussprechen bitte in
amerika hat geschlagen ganz cool also
ändert das ändern nicht aus nein das
ändert nicht alles weil es bedeuten
würde dieser krieg der seit 2014 im
osten passiert könnte pausiert werden
für wenige jahre vielleicht ich mir
putin möglicherweise würden sanktionen
zurückgefahren könnte erneut aufrüsten
und würde kiew wieder angleicht
auszuschneiden das ist nicht nur nicht
auszuschließen sondern sehr
wahrscheinlich wenn wir so handeln mit
so einer kaputten armee die heute hat
wir haben noch ein bisschen was
gelernt
lasst mich den satz bitte noch sagen
dass die annahme die russische armee sei
ums fünffache überlegen der ukraine das
zehnfache und werde innerhalb von drei
tagen erobert sich ja nicht um die sache
sondern um die reifen des der
hardware habe ich auf dem wissen wir
haben doch gesehen sie von echten waffen